ich möchte damit anfangen dass ich sage
ich höre immer das Reden von den zwei
Kriegsparteien das ist bereits eine
Verharmlosung und vergessen wir nicht
welchen Charakter dieser Krieg hat es
ist eine brutale
unterwerfungsoffensive gegen ein
souveränes Nachbarland zum Zweck von
dessen Zerstörung und Auslöschung seiner
staatlichen Identität verbrecherisch
nach Absicht und Ziel und auch nach den
Methoden jetzt gerade die gestrigen
Bombardements von Wohngebieten und zu
wenig ziviler Infrastruktur wenn Sie
Herrn Lavra hier zeigen der jetzt
plötzlich Schalmeien Töne
ausstößt und spricht davon spricht man
wäre zu Verhandlungen bereit ja zu
Verhandlungen bei denen das was bisher
annektiert ist in russischer antreibt
und über den Rest können wir verhandeln
das ist nicht ernsthaft und viele in
unseren in unserer Gesellschaft die
wollen Waffenstillstand sofort
Verhandlungen sofort das ist völlig
illusionär solange Russland überhaupt
keine Bereitschaft zeigt von seinen
Zielen
abzugehen und was Putin gemacht hat ich
hatte es vorhin schon eingeflochten
Teilmobilmachung Annexionen Verwandlung
der Gebiete in russisches Territorium
nukleare Drohungen
terrorbombers das sind verzweiflungsakte
und wir sollten uns dadurch nicht
ängstigen lassen sondern wir sollten das
zum Anlass nehmen zu sagen jetzt kriegt
die Ukraine wirklich alles was sie
braucht zur Flugabwehr zur Verteidigung
und auch zur
Wiedereroberung von
weggenommenem Territorium womit sie ja
schon große Fortschritte gemacht hat und
das einschließlich Panzer und
Schützenpanzer das ist ja das
kontroverse Thema und ich glaube der
Bundeskanzler der sollte sich jetzt
einen Ruck geben und sagen jetzt ist es
genug und wir geben die Ukraine nicht
Preis er sagt ja immer die richtigen
Sachen bei seiner Zeit in der Rede vor
den Vereinten Nationen jetzt mit den G7
aber die konkreten Konsequenzen daraus
die sind mir zu schwach zu zögerlich zu
spät und hätte man Ende April als der
Bundestag die Regierung beauftragt hat
schwere Waffen zu liefern entsprechende
Entscheidungen getroffen dann wäre viel
Gerät längst im Einsatz und viele
Ukrainisch leben werden wahrscheinlich
auch gerettet worden sie halten also
Putins Atomwaffen beispielsweise für ein
Bluff wenn er selber sagte es ist kein
Bluff dann ist es wahrscheinlich einer
aber es gibt auch rationale Gründe mit
denen man daran gehen kann anstatt jetzt
sich erpressen zu lassen wer sich
erpressen lässt hat schon verloren und
wird weiter erpresst und Nuklearwaffen
sind heute zur Kriegführung nicht mehr
geeignet
sondern nur noch zur Abschreckung und
wie gesagt zur Erpressung gegenüber dem
der sich erpressen lassen will
ist gibt bisher kein Anzeichen für eine
Änderung in der russischen nuklear
poststa wie man sagt also die
Stationierung die amerikanischen
Geheimdienste sind sehr gut
informiert sollte Putin tatsächlich eine
Atomwaffe einsetzen da wäre schon der
erste Einsatz einer sogenannten
taktischen
Atomwaffe die größer sein kann als
Hiroshima Bombe etwas was uns in eine
ganz andere Welt katapultiert übrigens
wären Indien und China die beiden großen
Mächte die ihm noch so einigermaßen die
Stange halten zumindest die nicht
öffentlich verurteilen äußerst
ungehalten darüber und es gibt auch
Kontakte zwischen den Regierungen in den
USA und Russland und auch zwischen den
Militärs in den
Informationen und Warnungen
weitergegeben werden also ich nehme es
ich nehme es ich nehme es als
Verängstigung versucht der Spaltung des
Westens besonders die German Angst ist
ja allgemein bekannt auch in Russland
und
ich glaube nicht dass es soweit kommt
ich kann natürlich nicht in seine
Gehirnwindung schauen aber putin wird
eskalieren egal was wir tun oder was wir
unterlassen Sie haben am Anfang in ihrer
Vorstellung der These gesagt dass auch
Verhandlungen so was wie aufgeben wären
viele Menschen wünschen sich aber
natürlich Verhandlungen weil die moralis
auf ihrer Seite aber die Vernunft spielt
ja auch eine Rolle und glauben Sie dass
durch die schweren Waffenlieferungen und
wenn das alles passiert der Krieg
wirklich beendet wird mit ihrer
Expertise also der Krieg wird nur
beendet wenn Russland bereit ist an den
Verhandlungstisch zu gehen unter Aufgabe
eines Teils seiner Ziele diese Ziele
sind ich habe es ja eingangs gesagt die
Zerstörung der Ukraine die Vernichtung
ihrer staatlichen
Identität die Ukraine hat kein Recht zu
existieren und wenn meine Überzeugung
stimmt das Putin nicht wirklich Angst
vor der NATO hat sondern davor dass sein
eigenes Volk vom demokratischen Virus
angesteckt wird dann wird er bei der
Ukraine nicht halt machen sollte er
seine Ziele durchsetzen deshalb habe ich
vorhin auch gesagt egal was jetzt an
Informationen und
Energiekosten uns bedrückt der Preis für
uns wird viel höher werden wenn Putin
sich durchsetzt davon bin ich überzeugt
und Sie können auch nicht sagen dass
Deutschland mit dem Verzicht und sagen
wir mal es ist uns jetzt ein egal mit
den Energiekosten sagen wir mal die
Inflation ist uns auch egal sagen wir
mal es ist völlig egal dass wir der
kranke Mann Europas und auch das ist uns
egal aber kriegen wir dann damit Putin
an den Verhandlungstisch können Sie
sagen wenn wir jetzt verzichten schaffen
wir eine Lösung für Ihre Frage
es ist sehr bedrückend aber der Preis
wird höher werden wenn Putin sich durch
und in karpaccio
vor drei Wochen in karpatsch bei einer
Konferenz hat ideal
jaronov russische Dissident sich
geäußert glauben Sie bloß nicht dass ich
an der russischen Spitze was ändert es
wird kein Staufenberg geben es wird
keinen neuen Gorbatschow geben die
Bevölkerung die Oligarchen die Militärs
forgettet und dann hat der Moderator
ganz verzweifelt gefragt gibt's nicht
irgendwas was zu einem Wechsel an der in
der russischen
Machtkonstellation führen kann da sagte
ja nur dass ukrainische Militär nur wenn
Putin einsieht dass er seine Ziele nicht
erreichen kann dann wird er zu anderen
Bedingungen als denen die er jetzt
vorträgt an den Verhandlungstisch gehen
und dann gibt es seriöse Verhandlungen
Politikwissenschaftler wissen ganz genau
das Verhandlungen der Beginn von
Verhandlungen keinen Zweck hat solange
die eine Seite sich auf der sie Straße
fühlt ich glaube nicht mehr das Putin
auch wirklich auf der Siegerstraße ist
aber das ist ja die herrschende Meinung
in Russland dass man ununterbrochen der
Bevölkerung erzählt die militärische
spezialoperation geht nach Plan hilf
gesehen sie einen anderen Weg wie mein
Putin an den Tisch holen kann gibt es da
vielleicht auch philosophische Ansätze
also vom Grundsatz ist es sicherlich
richtig dass man Stärke zeigen muss um
jemand an den Verhandlungstisch zu
bekommen also von einer schwachen
Position aus ist es sehr schwierig
auf der anderen Seite glaube ich müssen
wir noch mal eins sehen da würde ich
gerne mal einhaken was ist mit der
Verhältnismäßigkeit was ist mit der
Verhältnismäßigkeit der Mitte also wenn
es tatsächlich so ist dass wir in und
zwar insbesondere in Deutschland gar
nicht so sehr in anderen europäischen
Ländern ein immer stärkeres Problem
kriegen in Sachen Inflation in Sachen
Energiepreise riskieren wir da nicht
auch andere sozusagen Kollateralschäden
dieser Politik die auch schlimm sein
könnten ich meine nur zu sagen
das andere ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann also das ist mir zu
einfach gibt es nicht noch irgendwas
dazwischen also gibt es nicht auch einen
Punkt an dem man sagen würde also die
diese Schäden die wir hier erzeugen sind
doch zu groß und wir müssen
etwas an unserer Politik ändern
wir erzeugen keine Schäden
wir erzeugen keine Schäden das ist eine
Funktion eine Funktion dieses Krieges
ich habe in unserer Vorgespräch habe ich
ja gesagt ich bin Mitautor der
friedensdenkschrift des Rates der EKD
von 2007 als einziger Soldat ich bin
durchdrungen von der protestantischen
Friedensethik Prävention Absage an
militärische Lösungen
Grenzen rechts erhaltener Gewalt
vorrangig ziviler Konfliktbearbeitung
aber wenn Sie ein Gegenüber haben einen
Despoten der in seinem außenpolitischen
Arsenal nichts anderes hat als nackte
militärische Gewalt dann muss er
zunächst mit militärischer Gewalt
gestoppt werden und auch zurück gedrängt
werden und dann können wir weiter reden
und eins noch man hört von den
Befürwortern Waffenstillstand sofort
Verhandlung sofort hört man auch ohne
Gebietsabtretungen wird es für die
Ukraine nicht abgehen die Bedenken nicht
dass abzutretende Gebiete
Dörfer und Orte und Regionen sind in
denen Millionen von Ukrainern dasselbe
passieren wird was unter russischer
Besatzung in anderen Regionen schon
gewesen ist und ich brauche gar nicht
aufzuzählen Vergewaltigung Folter
Plünderung und so weiter ich muss eher
mal an Einzelheit denken Deportation
Deportationen von zum universellen
Menschenrecht kommen weil dann könnten
wir jetzt auch ist es ist leider so
müssen wir jetzt auch mit kriegen den
anderen Regionen anfangen was da mit den
Menschen passiert das ist natürlich
furchtbar aber wenn wir mal einmal auf
dem Punkt bleiben weil ich glaube jeder
ist sich hier sicher dass es eine
Kriegspartei gibt und einen Angriffs
kriege ich hoffe das müssen wir hier
nicht klarstellen dass es natürlich
logisch aber alle sind ja bemüht um die
Lösung und was ich mich frage ist wie
weit und das war glaube ich auch Ihre
Frage Herr Lüdke wie weit müssen wir es
militärisch schaffen damit Putin an den
Verhandlungstisch kommt wie viel Waffen
werden reichen wie viel Menschen leben
wird es noch Kosten das ist ja die Frage
die ganz viele Bürger auch umtreibt wird
der Krieg 10 Jahre gehen wird der Haare
gehen das sind ja alles Fragen die man
gestellt das fängt mit davon ab wie wir
die Ukraine militärisch stärken denn es
hat sich ja jetzt schon gezeigt die
russischen Streitkräfte sind nur in
einem überlegen in der Feuerkraft masse
statt Klasse und sarkastisch gesagt in
der Brutalität ihres Vorgehens so wie
wir das im Westen und ausseits der
Krainer nicht machen auf allen anderen
Gebieten operative Planung und Führung
taktische Beweglichkeit Führungssystem
Aufklärung Kommunikation
Logistik und vor allen Dingen in der
Motivation sind die Ukrainer überlegen
und was sie mit den begrenzten Mitteln
die sie bisher bekommen haben schon
erreicht haben dass es unglaublich und
jetzt haben sie durch die
zurückgelassenen Panzer mit Munition der
Russen beinahe schon mehr zusätzliches
Kriegsgerät als der Westen ihnen bisher
geliefert hat und ich glaube mindestens
mindestens die
Wiedergewinnung der Gebiete die bis zum
24 Februar noch nicht unter russische
Herrschaft waren ist die Ausgangslage
für Verhandlungen davon bin ich
überzeugt und ganz besonders der Bezirk
Carson ist in so vieler Hinsicht wichtig
Landwirtschaft ist das Tor zur Krim der
nord-krimkanal der stepping stone
gewissermaßen für einen Angriff auf
Odessa und so weiter als ich bin
überzeugt davon ich sagte vorhin
Verteidigung
Flugabwehr in viel stärkere Maße nach
dem was wir jetzt gerade erlebt haben
mit den Angriffen auf 20 Städte zivile
Infrastruktur Wohnhäuser
Kinderspielplatz und so weiter und dann
auch die gepanzerten Gefechtsfahrzeuge
zur Wiedereroberung von einem
nennenswerten Teil ukrainischen Bodens
damit Putin einsieht so geht es nicht
Herr gisla wie ist denn die die Stimmung
im politischen Berlin ja die Stimmung
ist fast so zum kippen würde ich mal
sagen wie wir sie auch in den anderen
Debatten in der Ampel die wir vorhin
kurz gezielt haben wahrzunehmen ist die
Frage nach der Verhältnismäßigkeit der
Mittel die stellt sich eben durchaus
auch jetzt schon gerade im politischen
Berlin weil man natürlich in einer
Demokratie von Wahl zu Wahl hechtet auch
wenn es jetzt erstmal eine Weile Ruhe
ist aber wir haben permanent
Meinungsumfragen wir sehen dass die
Zustimmung für die Ukraine immer noch
deutlich über 50 Prozent ist dass sie
aber abnimmt insofern wie gesagt die
Frage nach der verhältniskeit der Mittel
ist keineswegs trivial die aus dem
politischen Nebenkosten wird sich auch
irgendwann Stellen der Punkt ist ja auch
nicht von der Hand zu weisen dass
natürlich die Politiker an Eid
geschworen haben Schaden vom deutschen
Volk abzuwenden ihre Position für dich
große Sympathie habe heißt der Schaden
für das deutsche für das deutsche Volk
wäre umso größer wenn Putin gewöhne das
ist richtig aber es kann auch hier
genauso mit der Klimadebatte womöglich
an einen Kipppunkt kommen wo es eben ein
jahrelanges Darm gibt an jahrelanges
investieren in einen Frieden ohne dass
man den Eindruck hat er kommen näher und
dann kommt das wirklich näher der
sogenannte Zahltag bei der Demokratie
nämlich der nächste Wahltag und dann
habe ich wirklich die große Befürchtung
dass wir dann mit dieser Rhetorik diese
teilweise hier angeschlagen haben wir
müssen gegen die Kriegsmüdigkeit in
Deutschland angehen dass man dann glaube
ich auf nur noch eine Minderheiten
Zustimmung treffen wird weil ich glaube
das Gegenteil von Kriegsmüdigkeit wäre
Kriegs Begeisterung das kann es auch
nicht sein also es muss ein vernünftiger
rationaler Umgang sein und noch einmal
die Frage nach Verhältnismäßigkeit der
Mittel und nach dem was Deutschland
wirklich Front wird von Tag zu Tag
drängender und sie kommt ins Zentrum der
Debatte also ich würde sagen den
Kipppunkt sollte man nicht herbeirreden
und die öffentliche Meinung die hat auch
mit politischer Führung zu tun aber
irgendwann
sein dass der politischen Klasse Vertrag
ist und
ständig rumlaviert dann ist das etwas
anderes als wenn man die Dinge die ich
hier
habe für starke Waffen an die Ukraine
mehr und dennoch immer diese ewig
weitermachen mein kraftvoll zum Ausdruck
bringt und erklärt dass das ist meiner
Meinung nach eine Führungsaufgabe verbal
tut der Kanzler